et
c'est vous aujourd'hui à reed brody
bonjour bonjour merci d'être sur ce
plateau vous êtes américains avocat
spécialiste de la défense des droits
humains membres de la commission
internationale de juristes architectes
du procès contre l'ancien dictateur
tchadien hissène habré décédé il ya
quelques mois et vous avez longtemps
travaillé auprès de human rights watch
la guerre en ukraine a pris un nouveau
tournant depuis quelques jours et la
découverte de fosses communes et de
cadavres jonchant les rues des villes
reprises
reprises aux mains des forces russes
comment qualifie ton pénalement les
images que l'on voit depuis plusieurs
jours bon on est on est tous choqués
indigné révolté
par ce conte ce convoi en fait on est en
phase ii de beaucoup de crimes
potentiels
il ya des crimes de guerre les crimes
contre l'humanité il y a selon certains
une jeune sid il ya aussi
il faut pas oublier le crime d'agression
donc les crimes de guerre je pense que
c'est une évidence
quand on voit l'ampleur et des des
attaques quand on voit dans donc chacun
chaque chaque incident en soi pour être
une fabrication chaque chaque chaque
vidéo il faut le regarder il faut le
découper mais quand on voit l'ampleur
jour après jour
on peut dire qu'on est en face des
crimes de guerre un crime des crimes de
guerre justement voilà un crime de
guerre c'est une violation grave des
droits de la guerre et en fait ça se
résume à quelques a quelques idées c'est
surtout l'idée de deux daste distinguer
entre la population civile et les cibles
militaires on peut attaquer un soldat on
peut pas
attaquer un civil on peut
viser une usine de munitions
on peut pas viser un hôpital une maison
un appartement ce qui s'est passé à
marioupol par exemple on ne peut pas bon
on peut pas attaquer un théâtre plein
d'enfants où il est étiquetté très très
clairement enfants
maintenant chaque incident évidemment il
faut forer gardait ce qu'est ce que
est-ce que cette cet appartement est à
côté
d'une objets militaires c'est un travail
de fourmi a seulement fait ton et qui
prend du temps comment fait-on voilà
parce que la singularité de ce conflit
craignent un c'est que tout ça se passe
sous nos yeux avec les images que l'on a
un petit peu en décalé en fonction des
endroits ça a été le cas à abuja
jamais une guerre n'a fait l'objet
d'autant d'investigation ssi rapide mais
comment on fait précisément
c'est exactement la question d'abord
qualifié quelque chose de crimes de
guerre c'est 10 % du travail mais c'est
déjà un travail en soi donc il faut pour
chaque incident qu'on apprécie le
contexte
parce que madame les dommages
collatéraux une erreur de tir n'est pas
un crime de guerre il faut qu'ils aient
eu l'intention d'attaquer
un objet civile donc on doit découpé
comme vous avez dit on n'a jamais autant
de preuves il ya des milliers d'enfants
dé d'internautes qui qui qui découpe on
voit chaque incident de 10 angle
différent donc on peut présumer pour
certains un incident qui a eu crimes de
guerre ça se met ça c'est une partie du
travail le plus difficile c'est dans le
tout est d'en déterminer les
responsables de la chaîne de
responsabilités qui sont les donneurs
d'ordre est ce que c'est quelque chose
de calculé est ce que c'est le fait de
ci de là de deux soldats des décisions
prises sur le champ de bataille où
est-ce que c'est fait plus en amont
c'est ça l'enjeu c'est ça qui est
beaucoup plus difficile lorsque on voit
si on voit un soldat qui tous à bout
pourtant un civil enfin tout où le crime
et la bon il faut ensuite identifié le
soldat il faut ensuite voir si parce
qu'on ne craint ni etc c'est aussi ça
complique c'est c'est la population qui
se défend donc quand il se défend avec
des armes il devient des soldats des
cibles quand on met
de la tuilerie à côté d'un shopping com
s'était récemment le cas le shopping et
le shopping est atteint
c'est plus compliqué mais maintenant ce
qui est encore plus compliqué c'est les
bombardements sait des choses comme vous
dites des personnes qui se sont
peut-être même pas au théâtre de du cen
qui a pris des décisions à quel niveau
avec quelle autonomie est-ce que ce
convoi bouche à bouche à est-ce que
c'était une unité voyous ou est-ce que
ça suit une logique est ce que ça suit
une
désorientation des libyens délibère
organisée quand on voit en fait s'ils
avaient que bush à ça pourrait être une
chose mais bush à sa swiss coup ce qu'on
a vu dans dans tous les autres théâtres
et les les images que nous on l'envoie
vladimir poutine il les voit aussi où
sous soit il décide de ne pas les
regarder
mais donc quand il ya des crimes des
bavures ce qu'on devrait faire un
commandant ou digne c'est de dire à ses
hommes ses troupes n'ont d'ailleurs
récemment il ya la publication d'un
vidéo qui montre les ukrainiens qui
tirent sur des prisonniers russes de
guerre alors la réponse du gouvernement
ukrainien c'était stopper nous sommes
des civilisés nos soldats sont tenus par
les doigts de la guerre nous allons
investiguer tandis que moscou on dit le
contraire on dit que c'est des
fabrications et que ce qu'il a ce qui
met en accusation seront passibles tout
ça bien sûr s'inscrire dans un contexte
particulier qui est celui de cette
guerre de communication aussi entre les
deux camps vous avez évoqué un autre
point important qu'est ce qu'on appelle
le crime d'agression qu'on appelait
avant crimes contre la paix voilà de
quoi parle et ont de quoi parle-t-on qui
est compétent pour établir là pour le
coup les responsabilités et est ce que à
ce titre là les autorités russes quelle
qu'elle soit pour être un jour être jugé
et si oui par qui voilà donc on a des
investigations en cours pour des crimes
de guerre pour des crimes contre
l'humanité qui est un peu la même chose
mais à plus grande échelle cistes des
attaques systématiques et généralisées
mais ensuite il ya la crime d'agression
hier le fait d'attaquer un pays sans
aucun mandat voilà exactement parce que
selon la charte des nations unies on ne
peut pas attaquer à notre pays sauf en
autodéfense ou suivant un mandat du
conseil de sécurité
donc l'innovation d'un autre pays
c'est en fait à nuremberg de la plupart
des dirigeants allemands ont été
condamnés pour ce crime là
qui était considéré à l'époque comme le
crime international suprême qui
contenait en eux tous les l'accumulation
de tous les autres crimes le crime des
crimes de crime des crimes et donc et
c'est un crime deux des dirigeants donc
c'est ce qu'ils contrôlent et qui
peuvent décider la politique militaire
d'un pays donc c'est des leaders ce
serait éventuellement le président
les généraux
maintenant le problème c'est que pour le
moment il ya aucun tribunal qui n'est
compétent
à l'époque de la guerre froide l'union
soviétique et les etats-unis se sont
bien arrangé pour que ce soit pas un
crime d'antan pâle parce que quand même
les états unis aussi on parle de l'irak
par exemple donc d'aucuns parleraient
d'un tribunal qui pourrait être
exceptionnel un tribunal haddock sur le
type nuremberg qui pourrait juger demain
dans quelques mois quelques années les
responsables exactement donc c'est une
idée qui était lancée par le
l'avocat franco britannique philippe
sands ce qui était une grande amie qui
était notre avocat dans la sphère pinch
et équité repris par beaucoup de
juristes qui était repris par gordon
brown qui a été repris surtout par le
gouvernement de l'ukraine mais il
s'agirait là de créer un tribunal
sur les ures haddock comme noam bug a
été énorme bug n'y avait pas
les royaume uni la russie a fallu
soviétique et la france les états unis
la l'ukraine peut créer enfin l'ukraine
déjà dans le droit ukrainien il ya la
crime d'agression l'ukraine est
compétent mais les idées plus avancé
pense que ça pourrait être l'ukraine un
tribunal hybride avec le conseil du rap
ou avec la somme des gens râlent qui se
mettrait en place pour juger le crime
d'agression et là c'est d'ailleurs c'est
beaucoup plus facile à prouver c'est une
question de droit c'est qui est-ce qui
en russie a déclenché la guerre qui a
pris cette décision
et là c'est beaucoup plus facile à
déterminer
quid de l'application du concept de la
compétence universelle je me trompe
peut-être d'expression qui a été
appliquée dans le cadre de la guerre en
syrie et qui a permis pour le cou à
certains procès d'avoir eu lieu en
allemagne est-ce qu'elle pourrait être
appliqué là dans le cadre de la guerre
en ukraine voilà en fait là nous sommes
nous observons que en ukraine en ce
moment il y à déjà la justice
ukrainienne qui tique qui enquêtent pour
des raisons évidentes terrestrials si la
justice n'est il ya la cpi la cour
pénale internationale qui enquête sur
les crimes de guerre et les crimes que
la russie ne vous connais pas enfin de
se retirer du traité de rome
ce qui est aussi intéressant parce que
les etats unis qui sont les premiers à
soutenir maintenant l'action de la cpi
sont en guerre contre sont en guerre et
pourquoi ils sont en guerre contre la
cpi parce que les états unis ne
reconnaissent pas là le pouvoir de la
cpi de juger des américains pour les
actes commis à l'étranger en afghanistan
et pourtant on veut que la cpi juge les
russes pour des actes commis à
l'étranger en ukraine de crise il ya
beaucoup d'hypocrisie dans la justice
internationale
mais il ya quand même en ce moment donc
il ya la justice ukrainienne ilia la cpi
il ya dix pays dont la france qui ont
ouvert des enquêtes soient ou non de
cette compétence universelle qui veut
que il ya des crimes qui ne connaissent
pas de frontières qu'on peut les juger
par tous soient ou non en com comme
c'est le cas en france de défense de ses
citoyens des français qui ont aidé et et
le parquet antiterroriste a ouvert
plusieurs enquêtes voilà pour concernant
des français qui ont été exactement
touché on ne crie jamais la justice et
international ne s'est mobilisé aussi
vite et
comme en ce moment en quelques mots ce
dont on parle et crimes de guerre crimes
contre l'humanité génocides je crois que
vous vous écartez en tout cas
juridiquement cette notion crime
d'agression ce sont des crimes
imprescriptibles
c'est tous les crimes imprescriptibles
et donc ne sais pas si c'est pas
aujourd'hui si c'est pas demain ça peut
être dans le dix ans a fait en vingt ans
le temps la justice aura lieu souvent là
temps de la justice n'est pas le temps
de la politique c'est pas le temps la
guerre mais elle passera je pense
qu'avec tout six qui se déploie en ce
moment je suis optimiste qu'un jour il y
aura des contes en dhr merci beaucoup et
de brody est revenu ce matin sur le
plateau de parts et direct spécialiste
de la défense des droits humains merci
encore pour vous vos réponses